père yves le goff a créé le génie il y a
vingt ans sa spécialité le traitement de
surfaces notamment pour l'aéronautique à
plus de 50%
avec la crise il a dû licencier neuf
personnes restent cinq salariés avant il
avait des commandes pour 25 jours de
travail
la visibilité s'est encore réduite
maintenant c'est seulement de 5 à 8
jours
c'est très compliqué parce que nos
clients qui sont des entreprises plus
importantes que nous ne savent plus nous
dire ce qu'on va voir dans deux jours
donc si on réduit trop la voilure le
risque c'est qu'on puisse plus les
servir et si on ne le réduit pas assez
c'est qu'on a une charge financière qui
est trop présente
donc c'est un exercice très périlleux
qui se décident chaque jour chaque jour
une décision est prise et qui peut être
remise en question quant à moi je reste
optimiste mais c'est compliqué l'un de
ses clients ses cris la situe à temis à
besançon j'écris là en ce moment
plusieurs jours par semaine les ateliers
sont à l'arrêt
ces nouvelles presses à un nouvelle
façon horizontale
et ça nous permet de pouvoir passer de
travailler la nuit aussi donc c'est
aussi une question de productivité
vous avez peut-être de nouveaux
équipements il ya personne pour les
faire fonctionner ouais c'est ça fait
très mal au coeur c'est triste un
endroit au salarié vous les fait
travailler combien de jours par semaine
on voyait trois jours par semaine en
moyenne
crie l'un travaille à 75% pour
l'aéronautique
cette année thierry bisiaux prévoit une
chute de 45% de son chiffre d'affaires
suppression des cdd de l'intérim mise en
place de chômage longue durée
mais pour le moment pas de licenciements
envisagés
on préfère aller sur déjà ce chômage
longue durée à voir en parallèle de sa
toute cette action
cette action commerciale pour
diversifier trouver d'autres marchés
trouver de voie de développement et pour
le moment il n'est pas rare il n'y avait
pas de question de parler de de
licenciement ce qui est important c'est
d'être d'or dans le réel et surtout de
s'ouvrir
parce que c'est le moment oui si on se
ferme on peut vraiment avoir des soucis
il faut s'ouvrir s'ouvrir aux autres
écoutez les opportunités sortir de
l'entreprise aussi pour aller chercher à
faire ça c'est le boulot des équipes
commerciales et du chef d'entreprise
les entreprises qui travaillent pour
l'aéronautique en bourgogne franche
comté peuvent adhérer à un groupement
aéro microtech son rôle
fédérer ces professionnels et dynamiser
le réseau indispensable en temps de
crise les chefs d'entreprise sont un peu
seul mais le fait de pouvoir rencontrer
leurs pairs et de pouvoir dialoguer et
de trouver des solutions ensemble est
vraiment une force pour eux on essaie
d'ouvrir les entreprises à ce type de
démarche pour pouvoir voir comment est
ce qu'elles peuvent aller trouver
ailleurs et utiliser leur savoir faire
et trouver ailleurs d'autres types
d'activités l'année 2000 21 sera crucial
pour les entreprises du secteur
aéronautique qui emploie en bourgogne
franche comté 16000 sanary